il fut un temps où l'opinion d'une femme
n'avait pas d'importance. J'ai grandi avec mes deux
parents et avec ma sœur et ma cousine
et avec Kelly et toutes les filles et il y
avait toujours beaucoup d'amour dans ma maison donc
je veux la même chose.
[Musique]
cet homme est né pour ça et il est
né pour nous diriger et je me sens tellement
inspiré et
si fier
[Musique] les
droits d'une femme, c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours tenu à cœur
et de savoir qu'il y en a  les femmes
du monde entier qui n'ont pas de voix, nous
devons utiliser nos voix et sensibiliser les
gens
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je veux que ma fille grandisse en voyant une
femme quitter notre pays et c'est pourquoi
je suis avec elle
[  Musique]
[Musique]
et d'innombrables familles sont maintenant sans abri
dans ma ville natale de Houston. Les gens ont
besoin de nourriture, de vêtements, de produits de nettoyage, de
couvertures, de chaussures, de couches et de lait maternisé pour
bébés
[Musique]